PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
business is really heating up.
Your users are downloading
the app, viewing your pages,
clicking and tapping.
Is it 10 times a second?
1,000?
Maybe it's a million.
You're likely searching
for a messaging service
to help you capture these
events and turn them
into valuable
features and analysis.
Stay tuned because
in today's episode,
we are hoping you evaluate
the multiple messaging
options available,
including Pub/Sub,
to make your decision easy.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
All right.
So you are ready
to make your event
data accessible
and useful, be it
for automated machine
learning based recommendations
or even just basic reporting.
Building a data
pipeline is what will
enable a smooth flow of
your source device data
to your data warehouse or
downstream applications.
The data pipeline automates
ingesting, transforming,
storing, and routing
data to its destination.
A pipeline looks
something like this,
with the front end
landing zone for ingesting
the data, a
continuous processing
system such as Dataflow, Apache
Spark, or one custom built
for transforming the
data, and finally, a data
warehouse to store
and make the data
available for analytics
or for routing data
to a downstream application.
In this video, we're focusing
on the ingestion layer of data
pipeline and breaking
down your options
so that you can make the
best ingestions service
decision for your use case.
When you collect
data from devices,
each device will connect
to an API front-end.
These front-ends might
buffer data into blobs
before moving them to a blob
storage service such as Google
Cloud Storage or Hadoop's HDFS.
Buffering is critical to the
performance of these systems.
But what if the
idea of buffering
a large number of events on
your front-ends sounds risky
or if you need that
data in real time?
In this case, you need
a messaging service
to land your events
as they happen.
Google Cloud offers
messaging services
that support streaming
data, Pub/Sub, Pub/Sub Lite,
and Confluent Cloud.
You can also run
Apache Kafka yourself.
The easiest way to handle
messaging is Pub/Sub.
As we've discussed
in this series,
Pub/Sub is a service built
to make messaging just work,
whether you send one message
a day or millions a second.
With Pub/Sub, you create a
topic and publish messages to it
from anywhere in the world.
Anyone who needs to read these
messages creates a subscription
and sees all messages
in one place,
no matter where they originate.
The readers and writers can
scale independently and have
their own quotas, so
any team in your company
that wants to do something with
that data can just have it.
And for those writing
processing applications,
Pub/Sub has one important trick.
You can handle each
message independently,
allowing more flexible
parallelism then
you get with partition
based systems.
Overall, this means
that you simply
don't have to worry about how
your messages are ingested
once you teach your front-end
to publish to Pub/Sub.
Of course, it's not
just about ingestion.
For large scale
stateful processing
such as pipelines that
aggregate data intercessions
or join multiple streams, as
well as scalable connectors
to databases such as
BigQuery and BigTable,
Pub/Sub is integrated
with Dataflow.
Dataflow is its own
story, but suffice
it to say that you can create
an auto scaled pipeline,
pushing data to storage
with a few clicks in the UI
or write complex
processing logic
in Java, Python, SQL,
and other languages
and have Dataflow run the
code reliably for you.
There's another cool
thing that Pub/Sub can do,
which is supporting message
delivery to webhooks natively.
So you can do lightweight
but highly scalable
data processing and forwarding
in Cloud Functions, App Engine
or a custom app you run in GKE.
Pub/Sub does a lot, so it can
be expensive for some use cases.
As an alternative,
Pub/Sub Lite provides
a cost effective service for
real time data streaming.
Working with Pub/Sub Lite
has some notable differences
from working with Pub/Sub.
First, Lite has single zone data
storage, rather than multi zone
as in the case of Pub/Sub.
Second, Lite relies on
partitions or shards
to achieve parallelism
and horizontal scaling.
This is less flexible
than Pub/Sub's model
of [? pure ?] message
lifecycle tracking.
And third, with Lite,
you pay for the capacity
reserved for your partitions,
whether you use it or not.
So there is some
operational overhead
to optimize capacity planning.
A bonus of Lite is that it will
be familiar to Kafka users.
In fact, there's
even a client library
that implements the
Kafka client API.
This similarity also allows
us to provide an integration
with Apache Spark's structured
streaming, which is commonly
used with Kafka.
Like Pub/Sub, Lite is integrated
with data flow for processing.
It does not, however, offer
push delivery to webhooks.
Speaking of Apache
Kafka, no discussion
of real time streaming
is complete without it.
So your options include
running Kafka yourself
or using Confluent
Cloud, a managed service
from the founders of Kafka.
Running Kafka yourself is
flexible and can be very cheap.
In addition, Kafka comes with
a rich ecosystem of tools
that are simple to
deploy, connectors
to databases such as
BigQuery-- but operating Kafka
requires a substantial
commitment to administration.
Confluent provides
all the benefits
of Kafka ecosystem with
managed services and support.
When you choose between
Kafka and Pub/Sub,
it is worth considering
these factors.
Familiarity and
existing software.
If you already have
experience running Kafka
as well as applications
that rely on it,
it may make sense to
just stick with it.
Availability outside
of Google Cloud--
if you're planning to
run a multi-Cloud system,
Kafka may be a better
choice since it
is available on
virtually all platforms.
Integration with Google
Cloud- now Pub/Sub
is a first party
service, which means
a consistent authentication
administration security
features as well as
consistent support experience.
Access control-- when you have
multiple teams or companies
that need to work with the same
data, Pub/Sub's resource that
will access control and
administration system
can be very helpful.
In addition to a
flexible sharing model,
you also get independent
[? quota ?] and billing, even
between readers and
writers to the same topic.
In addition, you don't have to
think about different clusters
of popping up.
There is only one global
Pub/Sub of service.
Unpredictable growth-- now one
of the advantages of Pub/Sub
is that it does not make you
commit to a fixed capacity,
be it cluster size or
number of partitions.
This won't matter much if
your workload is steady,
but if you are growing quickly
or see spikes in the workload,
this model is very convenient.
So what's the TLDR?
When it comes to picking a
service to ingest and land
data, use Google
Cloud Storage when
extremely low cost is high
priority and freshness is not.
The downside is that
you keep more data
on the front-ends, risking data
loss and complicated scaling.
For real time streaming
options within Google Cloud,
you have Pub/Sub
and Pub/Sub Lite.
Pub/Sub is truly everything
that you need for most real time
cases, integrating seamlessly
with other Google Cloud
Services.
Pub/Sub aims for a
no ops experience
with automatic scaling and pay
for usage rather than capacity.
However, because
Pub/Sub does a lot,
it's not the cheapest
messaging solution.
When it comes to
cost efficiency,
Pub/Sub Lite delivers
scalable, real-time messaging
at low cost.
Like Pub/Sub, it has good
support with Apache Beam
and Spark for
processing and will be
more familiar to Kafka users.
It is, however, not
entirely no ops.
You will have to manage
your own capacity.
And there you have it, the
top tools and characteristics
to consider when building
out your data pipeline.
Hopefully we've made it easier
to pick a messaging service
for your event driven workload.
Which one of these messaging
options are you using?
Share with me in
the comments below
and ask us questions on
the Pub/Sub discuss list.
Thank you for joining us
today on Pub/Sub Made Easy.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]